hey never know what to do about my
haters
Oh what is going on with you dude and
check it now what are the most common
topic of questions that you wanted me to
address but I didn't really want to is
the topic of haters so what's a hater
according to my very credible source
reppin dictionary.com
I hate there is someone who simply
cannot be happy for someone else success
and this is true so how do I deal with
haters and how should I feel about it
well you already know what it is
LG AXA everybody likes to talk about
haters and the most common swagger if
the answer is oh I love mine is Bey
because that means I'm doing something
right
that is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard in my life
I wish the worst apart you [ __ ] I hope
you wake up class I call you if you look
at it you're ugly and sell all day do
you know why I'm like this someday the -
here's a little lesson for y'all if you
grew up bro most likely given a girl to
be a haven do you know what cuz we're
broke [ __ ] because enough to do
personally speaking as a professional
hitter you can take someone on their
success alone cuz that just made you
jealous
a jealous person the hater on two
different things I'll hate it because I
think you for [ __ ] that you're doing
right this [ __ ] over here feeling is
kids of [ __ ] breathe in oxygen and
blinking like a gun man you don't
actually hate the person just hate what
they got for example I got a homie who I
got mad love for but guess what I hate
to cut [ __ ] jumps evicted who signs you
successful ass son of a [ __ ] you were
up the first time I've been this foolish
fools in San Diego walking around like a
Jonas Brother having all these pills
flood and let them write meanwhile my
sorry ass is on the side like hey ladies
I want you to our gender wallets no no
[ __ ] we grow food you don't oh okay you
don't have to give me the finger
that's what do you all being all
successful and goal-oriented and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know as such I'm the
only person on YouTube that will pay you
to take my autograph
you wanna see my Konami what what shut
you will do the not what stranger danger
well somebody hates on you there's a
simple solution ignored and it'll go
away and if you can't do that there's a
simple solution to that to throw it back
in their face you ain't me I'll get your
o-chem treat you so ugly your shadow
don't wanna be your friend I'll bet
that's true
I hate you so much I'll [ __ ] slap you
with your left hand I do what
like you doing I'm just just playing my
song and I said get out yeah yeah just I
just want I just want you that much why
is it